ملهي استعداداته ومعلنا جاهزيته التامه
بات الجيش التركي في وضع لا ينتظر فيه الا
الاوامر للتحرك بريا داخل الشمال السوري
لكن ساعه الصفر التي يحسمها عاده القاده
السياسيون قد لا تكون حتميه اذا ما تسنى
لانقر تحقيق اهدافها المحدده دون ما قتال
ذاك احتمال اوحت به تصريحات وزير الدفاع
التركي خلص اكار اثر مكالمه هاتفيه من
نظره الامريكي رايد اوستن ليلى الاربعاء
الخميس لكن ما هو اكثر وضوحا كشف عنه اكار
عقب لقائه الخميس مع المبعوث الامريكي
السابق لسوريا جيمز جيم ثري كشف اكار ان
واشنط طلبت اعاده النظر في العمليه
العسكريه المحتمله لكن انقره طلبت في
المقابل ايفاء الجانب الامريكي بتعهداته
واضاف الوزير التركي ان بلاده ستواصل
مكافحه ما سماها التنظيمات الارهابيه التي
تهدد امنها واستقرار حدودها بغض النظر عن
الجهات التي تدعم تلك التنظيمات
تلك التوجهات اعاده تاكيد عليها اجتماع
مجلس الامن القومي التركي الذي تلقى احاطه
بشان الوضع العسكري الراهن وجدد تصميم
انقره على اتخاذ الخطوات اللازمه لعدم
السماح بنشاط اي تنظيم ارهابي في المنطقه
وفقا لبيان صادر عن المجلس حتى الان لا
يمكن الجزم بان صفقه المقايضه قد ناضجت
لكن المؤكد ان حاله الحشد والضخ الاعلامي
والتصريحات المتعاقبه عن قرب العمليه
العسكريه وفرت لانقر رافعه ضغط على الدول
المتحالفه معها وخاصه الولايات المتحده
وروسيا اللتين تتهمما بتوفير الدعم
والرعايه للفصائل الكرديه المسلحه
على ان موسكو تواجه ايضا انتقادات من
الجانب الكردي حيث طالبها القائد العام
لما تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه مظلوم
عبدي بمواقف اكثر حزما داعيا اياها الى
تحمل مسؤوليتها في قاف ما سماه التصعيد
التركيه في المنطقه باعتبارها دوله ضامنه
لاتفاق وقف اطلاق النار الموقعي مع انقره
اما الضغط على تلك الفصائل فيستمر يوميا
عبر غارات سلاح الجو التركي تحت اسم عمليه
المخلب السيف مصادر محليه اخبرت الجزيره
ان قصف تركيا استهدف مواقع لما تعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه في محيط مدينه منبج
بريف حلب كما اكدت المصادر ذاتها تعرض عده
مواقع لتلك القوات لغارات في ريفي الحسكه
والرقه شمال شرقي سوريا